- First things first.
Describe a perfect, romantic
evening with Chuck Liddell.
- A perfect, romantic evening.
Um...
Well...
Aw, man, I don't know, we're
gonna start with that, huh?
(hard rock music)
(playful child-like music)
(bell dings)
- I'm a lover, not a fighter, really.
- [Men] Aww, yeah, that's great.
- I like to surprise my wife.
- Dude, I'm not romantic at all.
- [Men Together] No?
- I'll shake your hand,
say "Hey, how you doin'?
(man laughs)
"Let's go to the room, baby."
- A bottle of wine, tons of chocolate,
and probably some old fights.
- Get a little drunk,
eat a little chocolate,
watch people beat the
shit out of each other.
- That is the coolest night, ever.
- Maybe go out to El
Gaucho, get a filet mignon.
- [Men] Ooh, yeah!
- Strawberries, you know,
wife's comin' in with some lace panties...
- [Men] Whoa!
- Playing video games in my basement.
(all laugh)
- Do you like puppies or kitties?
- [Chris] Do I have to pick one?
I grew up with cats and
then I became a puppy guy
later on in my life.
I'm goin' puppies.
- I got two cats, so I
guess I'll go with kitties.
- [Men] Yay!
- Meow meow meow meow meow!
- Team puppies.
- Do you ever lie down and
let them pile on top of you?
- Yeah, they're like my
kids or something, you know
what I'm sayin'?
- [Men] Aww.
- Does it make you laugh,
like (laughs)?
- Team kitty.
- Chuck Liddell will
have to tie-break that.
- He's gotta be a kitty guy.
- Uh, puppies.
(bell dings)
- [Men] Puppies!
- I'm a dog guy.
- What's your favorite kinda puppy?
- Great Dane.
- [Men] The toughest of all puppies.
- Burning question:
Beyonce or Taylor Swift?
- Oh, god, Beyonce.
- Not a second thought.
- I was always a Beyonce
guy, but recently,
Taylor Swift's kinda -
- [Men] Right?
- Makin' a mark.
- Beyonce all day.
- [Men] Ahh...
- All day.
- I like country, so, Taylor Swift.
- I'd rather listen to Nicki Minaj.
- I don't know, I learned
about truffle butter recently,
and it was gross.
- Who?
(men laugh)
- Truffle butter, it's
in a Nicki Minaj song.
You don't wanna know about it.
- Tell me about it.
- Well, it's when, well, well...
(all laugh)
- What's your favorite romcom?
- What? What's that?
(men laugh)
(bell dings)
- [Demetrious] Romcom?
- [Men] Mm hmm.
- First of all, what is a romcom?
- I don't even know
what romcom is, what...
- What's your favorite romcom?
- Who?
(men laugh)
- Ooh, that's tough.
Oddly, I like romantic comedies, um--
- Chuck, you know what,
you're the only person
who knew what a romcom meant!
- Oh (laughs).
- That deserves applause.
(clapping)
Iceman knows romcoms, guys.
- What's the movie where
he gets the girl pregnant,
and she hates him?
- Oh, "Knocked Up."
- Knocked up, there you go.
- "You've Got Mail."
- "Sleepless in Seattle."
- "The Notebook?"
- What's the one with, yeah.
"Notebook."
- [Men] Yeah, "Notebook."
- I guess we'll go "White Chicks"?
I mean I don't know if
you'll call that a romcom.
(men laugh)
- Oh, I fucking love
"White Chicks"!
- That is not a romcom.
- "The Ugly Truth."
- That's Catherine Heigl, right?
- That's a really good
one and it's really funny.
- That's a true romcom.
- [Men] Yeah.
- "She's All That," is that a--
- [Men] Oh yeah, that's great.
- I'll go with that.
I'm goin with "She's All
That," all right, cool.
- What do you like about that movie?
- Everything?
- Yeah, everything.
- It's when you put a (censor
beep) in a (censor beep),
and you have (censor beep),
and there's a residue,
- [Man] The truffle butter.
- Of a (censor beep) and (censor beep),
and then that comes out "truffle butter."
- I must have the damn
edited version, 'cause bro,
(men laugh)
I'm not listenin' to that.